[Musique]
tout cas j'aurais jamais pensé de voir
revenir ici quoi tu es pas fan de cette
vie
c'est pas la ville
c'est la maison
mais je suis la seule à mon être sorti
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé du boulot ah bon tu fais
quoi j'entretiens des piscines qu'est-ce
que tu fais de l'entretien
de piscine privée
et maintenant si tu es en bas tu faut
juste laisser porter d'accord
comment je fais ça
ok qu'est-ce qui te déprime
je suis ingénieur militaire dans le
génie civil non je veux qu'il me donne
le feu vert pour repartir sur une mine
mais tu veux repartir
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé j'ai eu un
accident de voiture sur la chaussée du
lac couchartra
je prends des tas de médicaments
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez repartir oui mais
est-ce que vous devriez repartir
tout autre question
[Applaudissements]
ça se passe bien les piscines
et plein de requins
[Musique]